If we take the car, we travel 4,500 km at 200 km per hour.
That's going to take 22.5 hours.
The throughput is 2 people divided by 22.5 hours, which equals about 0.089 people per hour.
For the bus, we're traveling 4,500 km at 50 km per hour,
and that's going to take us 90 hours to get there.
However, the throughput is 40 people divided by 90 hours,
and that's going to give us a much better throughput of 0.45 people per hour.
These two trends aren't necessarily opposed.
Improved latency often leads to improved throughput,
and sometimes improved throughput also leads to improved latency.
But the GP designers are really prioritizing throughput.
That's really the focus of their efforts.